i pledge allegiance
to the flag of the united states of
america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty
and justice for all
a moment of silence for those veterans
that are on the front lines that
serve in our great country and for those
that made the ultimate sacrifice
all right um that's not the are the
procedures that we will do
every time we started yeah would be the
moment of silence on behalf of our
fellow veterans
um the
members that are coming back i want to
thank you and welcome you back to the
committee
for the new members that are coming
forward um
welcome to state and federal relations
and veterans affairs
for those who don't know who i am i'm on
my 14th my 15th year
on state and federal asian veterans of
fierce committee
as a former chair vice chair um
ranking member i've worked hand in hand
with our fellow democrats
on all veterans issues along with other
resolutions too
but it's only a very
uh nonpartisan when it comes to veterans
issues
when it comes to resolutions we kind of
divide here and there
yeah but we do it in a civil manner
because we have some great friends
i'd like to introduce uh the officers uh
well
the committee uh for the committee first
of all
as representative as you see michael
crawford
is our vice chair um he is a returning
state representative
mike you want to say a quick uh 30 sec
their word
yeah i just want to say thank you uh
representative balacero
for all that you have done and that you
do
and i'm very honored and pleased to be
on this committee
uh i've also served in education um
and i uh you see the background that you
are channel or
whatever yeah so i'm also a usmc vet
and again very very honored to uh
thanks thank you representative market
walter is also a retired lieutenant
colonel in the western state board
um i wanted susan delimus on the
call
okay she's not on clerk
for the committee she's been a clerk
before um so she has
experience there she's a returning uh
representative how about ranking member
linda massa miller is she there
is linda on i am
okay before linda says linda and i
are very close friends for many years
she attended my wedding
uh relationship she would she's the
democrat ranking member linda you want
to introduce yourself
yes hi i'm linda massimilla and this is
my fifth term
and uh being in state uh state and
federal relations veterans affairs
and al and i have a very good
relationship
and when it comes to veterans affairs
al is all aces so i am pleased to be
back
on the committee and look forward to
working with all of you
well welcome um linda i'm glad
you just don't know me in my chest at
the gym okay
no problem that's a joke that we have in
the committee because that's
straight at times when i was a ranking
member
uh the next thing that we have i i have
to identify
um a technical support somebody
that will be evident in committee
zoom um and i'll get into that in a few
minutes on why we need to text the
fourth person committee member
so if you have experience in this here
i'd like to
let me know and we will um
work hand in hand because in the
committee rooms we're going to have zoom
tv set up and the committee members will
be in place
uh except for the public the public will
be on zoom
testifying on the committee
if representative can't make it in there
for some reason they're not going to
have issues with the colbin
then they will be able to go uh hybrid
during the committee meetings now keep
in mind that
during the committee meetings it's uh
this virtual thing is going to be kind
of tough
you know on asking the questions i've
been on a few meetings like this
and it it it's hard especially when
you've got veterans
that are homeless that call in for a um
bill that i
sponsored before it was tough on them
they lost the signal they got cut off
so we have to figure out how to handle
that
if you're not familiar what's going on
in the committees
in the we're going to be doubling up the
rims at this time we don't have a day
yet on what when we're going to be
in committee they're working on those
details right now
they're working on the details on the
blue sheets
if you don't know what a blue sheet is a
blue sheet is is is something that when
you have a committee hearing
that the public comes in or
representatives come in and they sign in
in support
or against the bill or they sign in to
speak on
on a bill so they're going to be
supposed to be putting that in the
calendar and they're going to be able to
go to
our committee um
site on the state webpage and be able to
sign in
before i go on to the next area and i'm
going to talk more about that in a
minute so
i forgot i want to introduce our staff
uh
is heather broly on here
heather is right it doesn't look like
she's on now okay
heather is a long time um committee
assistant's been up there for years i
think she's the senior
community assistant does a great job uh
she takes care of all our bills she
takes care of uh the
the committee uh reports that we write
on each bill that we
uh move forward with or against
okay so we'll be working hand in hand
with heather goalie uh
in the future here now the committee
researcher that we have
is uh bradley greenland now before you
have bradley speak um
the committee he cannot have any
committee member going at them
okay so if you're requesting assistance
from the committee researcher
okay um i recommend that you either
talk with myself or the vice chair
okay and then we will work hand in hand
you know
to make sure that the uh committee um
researcher does
and gets back in the information that
you needed
bradley do you want to speak on about
yourself there and
what you do sure so
um hello everyone um
so for my position like um
representative baldassaro said
um for if you want any research done on
any of the bills you'd have to go
through him
and request that research be done
um we are house many services is a
nonpartisan office
um where we um just kind of we
we present information to you um
completely nonpartisan matter we will
just give you
the fact that they are and
um we help you throw all the bills
during the
um when they're in committee
okay thank you brad i'm going to be
bringing i'll bring up something here
give me one second okay what i'm
bringing up here is uh on the um
responsibilities like uh what we're
going to be doing for the hybrid
committee
if you take a look at what i posted here
the the hybrid committees are going to
be like i said earlier
are going to be zoomed and hopefully we
have somebody who's technically
proficient
that will be able to assist us in moving
forward on putting things up
uh you know on the web so other people
can see it
the um tv screens are being set in the
in the rooms the double rooms there'll
be plenty of space in between for social
distancing
there will be a uh what they call
air exchanges uh prior to cdc
requirements
right now they're trying to get three or
four times
or two more times of what the cdc
requires don't ask me about
how these air exchanges work in my
office here i have an air exchanger but
it's a
heat pump type takes in air blows out
here
for heat and also uh air conditioning so
i imagine that that would be something
similar
to what these heat exchangers do or
these
air exchanges along with they're going
to have uv
system put in place there for um our
safety at the state house
or in the yellow beam so
our um assistant uh
secretary i will be the one that will be
putting name plates in place on the
tables and the committee rooms after
when you come in
i will be setting up once i identify
who's going to be sitting where in the
committee
i will be identifying somebody who's
closest to the door
will be a kind of of our emergency
response person
who if there's something that's going on
in the state house or we're having a
problem there
they will have the number for the
security and
you know or i will let them know hey we
need to call security we have an unruly
uh
guest in our uh committee room once we
start bringing the public back in
so we'll get into that a little bit more
as we move forward
now if the schedules on the hearings we
have nine bills right now as of
yesterday at two o'clock
the committee two of them are bills that
are
uh veterans bills that i believe
both of them have already passed before
but because of the
colvin and they were stuck on senate
bills they end up dying
so they're pretty simple veterans bills
the rest of them uh the seven other
bills the house
resolutions and i'm not going to bring
them up here um
you'll be able to go to the state page
you'll be able to click on committees
standing committees go down to state and
federal relations and veterans appears
and you can view
each one of the bills that are in
committee i'll be scheduling these bills
now there are 50 more bills and please
if i'm going fast
okay because i have like a half hour
then we're going to go right into the
guest speakers
stop me ask for you know if you have a
question you want to ask please ask
the there are 50 more bills that are
coming forward through the
lsas into the hp status uh once they're
entered into the system
then i will find out whether we're going
to get any of those
any bills out of those 50. some other
veterans bills
end up going to other committees like i
have a bill
on veterans
[Music]
disability money that's being taken out
of there being used for divorce but it's
not a marital asset
so that's gonna go to another committee
probably judiciary
uh we'll handle that our children and
family law i'm not sure what committee
they're sending that to but we'll find
out soon
so some veterans bills will go around
the committees
and there's certain bills that i i will
request as the chair
that they come to us as a second
committee okay so but i have to try to
you know keep an eye on those bills that
are in other committees
now i will be scheduling all the
hearings
okay for the uh the committee the zoo
we will have assisted with brad and
there's another technical staff
that will help us set up on the zoom
meetings there to get them in place and
ready and
get the addresses uh for zoom into the
calendar
so everyone can see it i talked earlier
about the blue sheets
they're working on that system there to
where somebody can just go into our
standing committee
sign in to support or against or sign in
to speak for the committee
if you look on the set up that
registration
page for members of the public like i
said that's in development
under the committee assistance here you
look at
on the bill filing um where
the committee assistant is the one who
will type up
our uh committee reports we used to call
them blurbs
i still call them blurbs but they
changed the name for some reason the
last term
the committee reports so and then she
will sign him
i'm one chairman who writes after a
executive session
before close a business to get the uh
report
whether it be a minority report against
a bill or a majority bill
for the bill okay to get it in so i can
get it filled out
uh signed off on it and then get it
turned in so we can move on to bigger
and better things
so keep that in mind there on when
you're making the motions
to move forward to pass a bill
uh you know again itl bill or interim
study would ever be
i will need to be prepared to have those
reports in
now linda who is pretty uh massive
representative there
was pretty sharp on having a game plan
when she comes into an executive
session and knowing exactly what her
committee's doing just like i
am as far as on the republicans and
making sure that i have blurbs and other
stuff ready to roll
so that way there we can get our stuff
turned in
so we can go up to the clerk's office so
we can get ready to go
onto the calendar then to the floor
um let me see where we at here um
the committee assistance also uh will
handle
uh pretty much anything like uh that
comes in and out of the committee
she also is non-partisan the committee
clerk
um the committee rather assistant has so
many committees i think she's got like
three or four committees
she's responsible for in her office or
in another
area there'll be a more likely in her
office there'll be a section you can
grab the bills
copies of the bills when we're there and
you will also have them on the table
uh a folder that we put out there with
the bills
she's the one that makes sure that all
this is done for you
the committee assistant
works for us to make it easy she's
non-partisan also so keep that in mind
she does not get involved
in any politics and she's there to
assist you and she's been there for
years heather and she's a great help to
us
uh you know she'll make a big difference
for our committee
now the researcher and he's already
talked about him if you look and see
where i posted on the researcher
you know he takes care you know on uh
the whole statuses there for the
committee
uh he makes them sure that we're um
you know if there's something we need
for the committee he'll be he's on the
ball to make sure that we get it there
a lot of times any bills that come up
into the committee
uh that have been heard before i like to
have the history
of that bill to come forward so we can
get a copy to each one of the members
so they know what has happened what
happened with that bill in the past
and what has been done on it whether it
passed the field
okay so hopefully uh you know we'll be
able to get that on
on whatever bills that we're in our
committee before that are coming back
for
another vote okay and then of course
uh we follow up with the clerk you know
to get the minutes you know for the file
or
in the past let me see here
the researcher as i was stating area if
i sound a little confused
i'm trying to read myself from the
computer so i can stay
in order the researcher
plays a big part in our committee okay
um and we will need his assistance here
like if there's amendments or stuff that
needs to be done
we're trying to figure out how we're
going to handle this here
being virtual okay because uh the
legislative services
uh they're not in there full-time so i
don't know how that's going to work
yet when we're in committee hearings
especially executive sessions
when we need to do an alt amendment to a
bill
in order to get it passed okay
i'm going to move down to the tech
support uh staff
uh earlier i was trying to get on here
at 9 30 and i made a phone call
you know because we wanted to get
legislators on here prior
to uh 10 o'clock cause like i said i'd
like to start right on the
10 o'clock if i am not in the room at 10
o'clock when we're having a public
hearing
for some reason sometimes the chairman
is tied up
then the vice chair should open up the
meeting okay whether i'm there or not
that meeting will start at 10 o'clock in
the morning unless you know
i am there to postpone it for a few
minutes or whatever
but like i said our meetings will start
at 10 o'clock
um let's go to committee members
well before committee members for the
republicans uh
in the democrats when we do an executive
session
uh we like to caucus what i mean by we
caucus here we wanna we have to get
together identify
a game plan for each one of our parties
on the certain pieces of legislation
like i said earlier when it comes to
veterans most time we're pretty much
clear but when it comes to
[Music]
resolutions then we have to uh
each each party has a game plan on
whether they support or don't support
so that's why we we caucus prior to a
executive session starting so keep that
in mind
if your hearing starts at 10 o'clock
exact
that means you might want to caucus at 9
okay in order to get a game plan okay
let me see we're out here
reading
okay if you look at where the chairman
responsibilities
are there there's a opening script
that's at the bottom of this here that
i'm required to read
okay prior to opening up a um
any type of meeting confirming
compliance with executive orders
with the governor's executive order okay
because in 91a it's important that we
make demo sure that we have the
right information put out there to the
public
and exactly we're going to pause to
ensure that we all have video on in our
in their chairs before calling the
question
the clerk will call a roll call
prior okay and you will let her know
uh if you're you know if you're
i hope to have everyone in the room for
executive sessions
okay so that's my game plan anyways but
if for some ungodly reason
we can't uh then
we have to change the way we do business
here on exec
because i prefer face-to-face when it
comes to voting
okay but most of the time if you're
doing a
zoom meeting you want to say who you're
with uh if there's anyone else in the
room uh
for public reasons for 91a reasons
now brad do we do are the zoo meetings
going to be recruited
uh yes they will be and they'll be
recorded and um
streamed on youtube as well okay good
now the committee clerk the tech support
person i don't have anyone right now
if there's somebody that is an expert in
these areas um
please let me know and then we'll adjust
and from there and have you work with
bradley
and to get us up to speed on where we
need to be with the zoom
meetings i'm fortunate because my wife
is a gis
database administrator the better half
keeps me out of trouble so i'm fortunate
i'm blessed by god so
um you know it makes life easier for me
the committee clerk on the record of
attendance information
at the beginning of meetings that's
going to be her responsibility to do a
roll call when i ask her to
you know and everyone be there president
at 10 o'clock so we can get the meeting
started
once we get the roll call um her other
duties will be to take the minutes
you know email the committee assistance
uh
she'll she will be sent roll call sheets
for exec sessions
okay that will be given to her but uh
more
like i said i plan on holding exec
sessions in the committee hearings
if for some reason you cannot make an
exec session
if you're a democrat you need to let the
ranking member know
so she can work with your team to get
you replaced
okay and that has to be done the day
before the executive session
not i'm not sure if they're going to
change that policy because of uh what's
going on with the covert stuff
as far as the republicans very important
i need you to get with my vice chair
if you cannot make an executive session
very important
for one reason another you have to let
him know
and then we will get the message to the
republican side
so we have a replacement for your
executive in the executive session
so keep that in mind because i mean for
republican democrats
it's very important for us to make sure
that we have a quorum
in order to do business in the committee
hearing
now keep in mind when we have committee
hearings we do not use robert rules
we use masons okay and
that those are the rules that we use in
committee
so i recommend some of you is to uh
educate yourself
on masons on the committees on how to
perform you know and run a committee
and you know and what you can do and
what you can't do
one of the things i found out throughout
the years
there's always somebody in there that's
always trying to silence the majority of
the minority
and they try to move the question that
is unauthorized you cannot move the
question in the committee during debate
okay until the last person speaks or
if the chairman decides it's repetitious
then
he will move for a vote but i'm a
freedom of speech guy and i
every representative in the committee
has the right to speak
and we are civil to each and every one
of us together
because we're in this we're a team and
we have to work this together whether we
agree or disagree
we do it in a civil manner
all members okay keep in mind must
identify uh one
email address for use for zoom
invitations
make sure that the clerk uh knows
like for instance i have two emails i
had to answer an email and tell them
i'll use my legislative email
okay so that has to be sent in uh to
make sure that they have the right email
uh let me see where we send individual
zoom you all should have got an
individual zoom
um invitation from our committee
assistant
there's gonna be a means to confirm your
receipt that they're setting up
okay i didn't get it on this one but
hopefully uh
they'll be set up soon where it's an
automatic receipt that you received it
or somehow they know
members must inform their cheers if they
will attend in person or remotely very
important
we need to know this if participating by
phone provide
phone numbers so they can be recognized
also when you log in by phone make sure
your name is
uh there so we know who you are we'll
make it easy on brad or whoever our tech
is
that's uh keeping an eye on who's
calling
you know in in whether it's the public
or not
you know instructed not to share
their zoom link you cannot share
well you know i'm going to disregard
that because i don't know why
like myself i shared the zoom uh
with the public and i put it on with
other representatives because it wasn't
in the calendar
normally our resume meetings our
committee meetings are in the calendar
for some reason this one didn't get in
uh but because it was posted
it was sent out to each one he is
normally they posted on the door
um you know 72 hours prior
then we're protected so and i did call
on why it wasn't in the calendar just to
you know
get an idea on this here so
i don't know why that that is there you
know i'm not sharing the uh
zoom invitation back can you touch on
that one
mainly for um okay so
um each link it's set for having your
name on it and we don't want
um other we want representatives to
share it with members of the public so
they are
allowed so they come into the as a
panelist and not as an attendee
okay now like for instance the page of
the uh the invite that i receive
uh the schedule from heather i cut and
pasted
that into a uh like a republican page
that we have
so other republican reps would know and
i'm sure linda would want to do the same
thing represent
uh is that proper uh so the notice that
she sent out i believe that had the
public link on it
and um i believe that that should be
that should be fine
okay so that's the one that we can share
then okay that's what we wanted to clear
up then
okay uh if it is like i said if
participating by phone
uh please make sure we recognize that we
know uh who is on the phone call
you'll notify the chairman uh you know
the vice you'll let me know and then
uh the ranking member will let me know
and who will not be able to attend
if in fact it'll be as a replacement for
them during exact session
the system will automatically resend
invitations on the morning of the
hearing
okay so you should get another uh
invitation but don't count on it
uh like myself when the invitations come
in for zoom because i have so many
this is my second zoom meeting today i
put in a certain folder so i know on
certain date that i clicked that on
for that meeting so keep that in mind
this is going to be tough there because
if you're like us republicans
you know we have caucus zooms we have
systems that zoom
we're zooming everything so it's uh
tough to keep
up with there on and plus other uh
you know meetings that we do so but
this is your priority is our hearings
in our executive sessions
now if we end up with nine bills i can
tell you right now nine bills to me
that's probably two days of um
hearings and maybe two days of executive
sessions
now the chair reserves the right to hold
an executive session
um after a bill is heard that's going to
be put on the calendar every time
okay so um keep that in mind
during the um the hearings we want to
make sure you decorum you're properly
dressed when you come into the hearing
um you usually raise the hand features
do not speak unless recognized
i'm going through quick because i got
about one minute to go here before
our first speaker you're going to notify
the chairman if i'm able
uh to attend where am i at here
um
okay you're gonna mute and unmute
themselves because that return zoom
meeting is very important to stay muted
and then if you want to speak you just
click it real quick and then you know
or there's a hand system here and i
haven't figured out how i'm going to
handle that yet on raising the hand to
speak i have to
there's a uh have video on when they are
in the meetings turn off when away from
monitor or so
on the phone okay you got to make sure
you can't have anything else on in the
room
and um can you explain that when there
uh brad have video on when they are in
the meeting
turn off when they're away from monitor
on the phone so if they're on if they're
up if they're on the phone
and they have their camera and um we
just wanna make sure they're muted
and uh if they're on the phone and their
videos on then
um it might just be distracting
okay all right um
when i get when we get done with the the
briefs here which we're going to go into
right now
then uh we'll have a chance for you all
uh to open up and ask questions and
introduce some other stuff here
okay and you can read uh after that i'll
put this back up later their script
you know that i'm required as a chairman
and other stuff that you're required to
do
okay i'm gonna make a switch here
let me go to my
see if this is it
okay is um kevin um the director forrest
on
kevin are you there
it looks like he's raising his hand um
in the end
and i will allow them to talk one moment
everyone here kev um kevin forrest is
the director of the manchester va
medical center
and the reason why i brought these uh
different groups uh
you know leaders on of those areas are
to make sure that one veteran
is not left behind and not forgotten so
each one of our state representatives on
the committee know how to handle
and where to send a veteran for
assistance
um kevin uh mr flores welcome aboard
are you there kevin just promoted him to
being a panelist
um he is muted right now
and if he has his brief uh that he i
don't know what he has
the manchester va does a great job i use
the va
because i'm an activist and i have full
coverage insurance but i use them
as a disabled veteran and they do a
great job over there
you there yet kevin
right you said he's on i believe this is
him
on it's um it doesn't say his name it
says
v-h-a-m-a-n-b-e-m
one um looks like another person is
see this is the stuff we have to work
out when we're in committee
it's gonna be tough
hi alex kevin here can you hear me yes
kevin uh welcome aboard there
so uh sorry i've got the screen looks
different here we can't unmute or uh
pull up the screen that's why i'm not
sure whether we've got
uh whether you're controlling it from
that side so the screen's
looking a little different but um brad i
guess if you're on there as i would
i've still got uh representative
baldicero's screen up is there a way i
can share my screen for the presentation
i just took my screens down
all right let me see here
you should have an option at the bottom
of the screen
yeah i'm not seeing the screen it says
share screen
on the bottom hey just
all right i think we're working through
this here now so give me one second
all right can i ask can everybody see
the uh the screen
my screen now
i don't see it at all
all right well what i can do uh let me
just try
one one other thing here
if not i'll go through and i'll make
sure that the slides can be handed out
to
to everybody but let me just give this a
shot you got to get stellar in there to
spray you away kevin
all right how about now any anything or
no
if possible you could always um send
email them over to me and i can share my
screen
all right let me do that real quick
it'll help
get this following along
now when it's done he has about 15
minutes and then if anyone has a
question
uh they'll put their hand up glad you're
able to see who
has got questions because i can't oh yes
i am brad could you give me your email
address please
yeah sure it is um bradley.greenland
at leg dot state
dot nh dot us all right hold on i've got
bradley
up here i've got it here
all right you should have them now sorry
about that folks
why don't i uh i'll go ahead and
it doesn't look like you're um oh is it
coming up now all right
so apologize for that we'll we'll uh
go here so first of all so thank you i
appreciate the uh
the the introduction there and to all
you know the new legislators
thanks so much for uh you know serving
on the
federal relations and state veteran
veteran affairs committee and really
being an
advocate for all new hampshire veterans
here so my name is kevin forrest i'm the
medical center director here and
a veteran and a native of new hampshire
so truly it's
it's an honor to be able to serve in
this capacity and
and continue serving uh new hampshire
veterans after i retired out of out of
the army so
what i wanted to do this morning is just
go really quickly about the services we
offer and some of the kind of the
current state of the manchester va
and uh and to give you really a vantage
point of of what we do
here so first thing so the department of
veterans affairs
you know large organization i mean
currently led
you know by by secretary wilkie and i
want you to know there's there's three
main arms to
the department of veterans affairs the
veterans health administration
which is what we are here uh and you
know dr richard stone
the executive in charge of vha is the
one who
has uh oversight and responsibility for
you know the 150 plus medical centers
throughout the country
and all the policies and the delivery of
health care to veterans
second up just understanding we have the
veterans benefits administration
i ended up by dr paul lawrence who's the
under secretary for benefits
and that takes care of all the uh you
know the veteran benefits whether it be
the home loans uh education benefits
everything to do with everything that
veterans
uh are entitled to from a from a benefit
standpoint
and then thirdly is uh the arm is the
national cemetery administration
headed up by mr randy reeves who's the
under secretary for
for memorial affairs i bring this up
just to understand
that we really look at ourselves as one
organization here
and you know veterans don't uh i think
really kind of discriminate between the
three of us you know they can come into
the medical center
at any time and have questions about
their benefits or about cemetery uh
benefits
and we do our best you know where we're
networked with vba
here in the state to be able to kind of
serve as a one-stop shop
or at least get them to the right folks
um
to be able to answer their questions and
serve them uh
so you know generally you know we we
don't like to think of ourselves as
just handling the healthcare arm of the
va here we want to be inclusive to all
veterans for all their needs
just a little bit about eligibility as
this comes up is understanding
you know veterans not all veterans are
eligible for for health care
um what we do when we get out of the
service is you know you're evaluated for
service connected conditions and you're
a that's done through the vba the
benefits administration
and there's you're assigned a percentage
uh of disability and that determines
what health care benefits you are
entitled to so we all go through this
eligibility
uh process as we get out of the service
and that's really what drives
you know our uh our veteran population
here in new hampshire and who we take
care of
you know just noting that
you know generally every person who
served in the active military and is
separated
um you know is eligible for certain
benefits and even in certain
conditions and other than uh
other than dishonorable there's certain
benefits that apply
uh you know like certain mental health
benefits and we just want to make sure
that we're here to take care of those
veterans in need
and then certainly the last piece we
look at is you know current former
members of the reserve national guards
who are called
active duty and deployed and you know
since the beginning of uh
you know operation iraqi freedom
enduring freedom you know as
as uh reserves and guardsmen return um
stateside here you know we provide that
care there's certain eligibility to
provide that
out um you know for for up to five years
in certain uh cases so that's really who
we take care of and how that's
determined
just to know how we're arrayed
throughout the state here
um these are our locations i'll tell you
there's you know about a hundred
thousand veterans in new hampshire here
of which we have about 25 000 enrolled
to the manchester va
there's another 10 000 or so enrolled to
uh the white river junction va
and that's predominantly those veterans
that live up in the uh
you know the hanover lebanon area up
there where the white river junction va
is closer but we have a very close
relationship
with the uh with the white river
junction va
and uh and sharing services and taking
care of veterans
you can see just you know with the gap
there of like 35 000 veterans
enrolled and a hundred thousand veterans
in new hampshire we have outreach
programs where we continually go out
and look for those other veterans who
may not be aware that they're eligible
for services
and we spend a lot of time trying to
bring them in and giving that they're
giving them the option of letting them
know that we are here
uh to provide those services you know
they earned you know they earned that
that health care and those benefits and
we want to make sure that that they're
aware of them
just our locations throughout the state
you'll see you know certainly the main
medical center and manchester va
and then we have four what are uh
community-based
outpatient clinics may hear these
referred to as cbox
uh we've got two over in the uh seacoast
area in portsmouth and somersworth
and then we've got two up north one in
in tilton
and then another up in conway in the
mount washington valley
uh we also have
lease space down to the brady sullivan
tower in downtown manchester here
where we've got some of the support
elements for manchester um
and the non-clinical elements but we
also offer our whole health program to
veterans down there so
these are the locations where we provide
services
just to give you an idea of what we
provide here
i've got a a summarized list here but
certainly primary care
is big and our home-based primary care
where our staff goes out to homebound
veterans to make sure that they get the
care that they need
we have an urgent care facility here and
a strong
move of providing women's health
mental health care is certainly
front and foremost on our you know
inventory of services here
and then certain specialty care where
it's you know we've got like
gastroenterology neurology
endocrinology cardiology a number of
these specialties that
you know we'd like to be able to serve
veterans here so that they don't have to
go out in the community or sometimes to
our sister facilities out there
just from a travel time standpoint um
we have surgical services here we have
three operating rooms and a procedure
room
and we do general surgery vascular
orthopedics
and ophthalmology here and a big
cataract program so those are very
popular with our with our veterans uh
also doing
um you know gaster gastroenterology and
and
endoscopy and scopes colonoscopies and
such
pain management is really big with us as
far as acupuncture and chiropractor
and physiatry and having a pain
management service
certainly with a quest to keep veterans
off opioids
uh and a lot of of uh partnership
between the pain management
pain management and mental health care
there we have
rehabilitation services this is like
physical therapy and occupational
therapy
audiology speech therapy geriatric care
we have a community living center which
is long-term care facility
in the manchester va so we currently
have 41 beds
where we serve veterans both who need
rehab coming out of a hospital
as well as long-term care or like
nursing home care
you know and also i'll just finish up
with social work and prosthetics and
then certainly our ancillary services
which serve veterans
needing uh clinical services uh here
at the medical center i will say that
what is not on here is dental services
this is always a big one with veterans
um we've had to close our dental clinic
with um
with covid and we're looking at trying
to get that opened back up but we've got
some facility
construction to do to make that
compliant in a coveted environment
but just knowing for you that you know
there's very strict eligibility criteria
for
dental um for dental
uh being a hundred percent um service
connected disability and
and that that's that comes up a lot with
uh with veterans and different groups of
wanting to expand dental services
all right just to know um al if you can
send out the the slides here
um this shows kind of what we offer at
this c box but in the interest of time
here i'll i'll go through this real
quick and
and uh um see box generally it's primary
care mental health and we do a lot of
telehealth
so that veterans don't have to drive all
the way to manchester
you can see our expansion updates we've
got a lot going on
with uh expanding for services here
we've got a new building out front which
will
be completed in the summer of of this
year and then opening up a new urgent
care and mental health
facility uh as well as a new women's
health clinic which will break ground
here
there's a lot of compliance factors we
look at to make care
safe and accommodating for women
veterans you know you've got to think we
have
women veterans that come in that have
been subjected to military sexual trauma
and things like that and we want a safe
environment where they feel comfortable
coming in for their care and then just
some other construction projects
coming down the pike here and another
year here
to help with our to help with our
infrastructure
let's hear from an urgent care
standpoint just important to know we
have an urgent care that's open seven
days a week here from eight to four
thirty
uh the only days it's closed is uh our
federal holidays
um but this you know mirrored up with
the mission act and veterans having the
ability to go out on the community to
like a clear choice or convenient md
uh really gives veterans often uh
veterans options of urgent care both
at the medical center here as well as in
the in the network
then we always uh just make sure that
they know you know if it is an emergency
that they are covered in new hampshire
and they need to go to an emergency room
and not one of the urgent care so they
get the right level of care that they
need
um and then we make sure that those are
bills are paid
uh making sure that the notifications
are done after an ed
visit just a little bit here about the
women veteran and sexual gender minority
health services
programs you know i had mentioned us
doing the special women's veteran clinic
that we're breaking ground on
but you know we focus on women's health
primary care and mental health
all within the scope of this women
veteran program clinic
and then we offer an lgbt service clinic
for those veterans
possibly in transition or identifying
themselves as lgbt
so we give them a safe place to receive
that that care and just knowing that you
know
everybody every veteran is welcome at
the manchester va for their care
just note that we can't do it alone and
we are reliant on care in the community
and
and so we are not a full service
hospital so we have
uh you know partnerships both with the
other va's in
in new england here as well as using our
local providers out here and veterans
move back and forth between these
systems to get the care that they need
um this has been you know a big learning
curve over the last few years with the
initiation of the choice act and then
the mission act but we do a pretty good
job
of getting folks out there for the care
that they need
just note that we also have like a
homeless veteran program where we
have a lot of partnership community
partners that we work with
all looking to make sure that every
veteran has a place to live
and we take care of their homeless needs
so there's some some context here for
you but
you know we also have a primary care
team that provides care
to homeless just veterans let you know
the last
thing i've got here is just some of our
big challenges now we continue to look
at reimbursement
making sure that the hospitals out there
in new hampshire are paid
for the care that we provide and we've
alert worked a lot with the legislature
with that
to make sure that as we've gone so fast
with these different
uh programs with care in the community
that we need to make sure that people
are paid
and so we've worked a lot with that and
just know that you know right now
i mean all of our efforts as well as
every other healthcare organization has
been
covet operations taking care of patients
while being able to balance that of
taking care of their other health care
needs
and then we've been full steam ahead
with our vaccination clinics
and see that moving you know throughout
2021 here
of making sure that every veteran who
wants a vaccination
gets one it's all part of our fight
against covent here
the last part i'll bring up here is just
understanding you know
veteran suicide is still the secretary's
number one clinical priority
and i you know what i would ask of any
of you out there is that veteran crisis
line number
uh is to put that into your cell phone
and keep that that you never know
uh when you're out there on a saturday
night or whatever and seeing a veteran
in crisis
it could be that phone call away and
helping them out
and so i i never uh i always take the
chance every every audience i get to
to promote the veterans crisis line and
know that it's out there
sorry al i know we got a little hiccup
of uh getting going here but
uh i'll stop for any any questions and
try to keep us on track
director forest you've done a great job
as usual um
brad do we have any questions uh from
any of our representatives sorry
looks like uh representative the shades
has their hand raised
go ahead represent
i was just wondering if you go back one
slide so we could read the phone number
again i'm trying to i missed the last
two numbers of it just so i can save
that in my phone
or it is 1-800-273-8255
and then you press one just note that is
the national
uh suicide uh crisis line and then
there's a press one option
that triggers into the veterans crisis
line but it's all networked into the
same thing
okay okay thank you okay anyone knows
brad
representative bedford what's up henry's
yeah
i was wondering if you could just
clarify i know there is a cboc
located in littleton i'm assuming that
falls under the white river junction
jurisdiction
it does
is that just because of geographical
location closer to white river junction
versus manchester
it is and when they looked at that i
know they've divided up you
the keane seebach is also under white
river junctions uh command and control
there and i think it's just for that
specialty care when they need it you
know in in uh
kind of the i-91 corridor there of
easier to do that referral back to white
river junction so
it's been arrayed that way since since
i've been with the va here
just wanted to make sure that the folks
here knew that there
were others within new hampshire they
just don't necessarily fault under the
manchester jurisdiction versus the white
redemption and just to be clear you know
when when we get those questions
if someone calls you know we do our best
to answer just do a
soft you know hand off to to the right
folks it's not like we say
oh that's a vermont thing and you know
you have to call them you know we're
we're one team
questions
and i'm not trying any other hands
raised now okay
i want to thank you very much dear uh
director force
and i'm sure that you educated them all
and understand what's going on in the va
that you
believe in not letting one veteran left
behind so thank you
oh i will and i'll just say you know
thank you everybody for serving veterans
i will give you my
my cell phone here which is uh
912-257-8284
again that's 912-257-8284 and if you
ever have any questions
please feel free to uh to reach out and
uh thanks representative balducero
my pleasure to meet everybody here today
all right thank you have a great day
is uh general micheladas uh on board
i guess he is i will promote him right
now okay
uh the general is the um national guard
guru he runs the show over there does a
great job as the adjutant general and uh
welcome aboard general
and he does have a brief answer
hey yes sir can you hear me now
and do you see the slides
not yet all right
i know the general's probably done this
a million times
um i because my age sir
am technically challenged so i have
someone here
helping me
you don't need a marine to come over
there do you yeah
hey if we could in the guard we would
take them
uh do you see the slides now or we do
you do the floor is yours sir
all right thanks so yeah cern our
representatives
committee members um david mikulitis the
adjutant general for the new hampshire
national guard
um thanks for taking the time to have us
on today yeah
i'm not going to read the slides i'm
just going to try to give you a broad
overview of what the new hampshire
national guard and the department of
military affairs and veterans services
is so you know going down memory
lane taking a look in the past about two
years ago
senate bill 209 changed the adjutant
general's department into the department
of military affairs and veterans
services
i codified into law to sort of um
bring all this disparate veteran sort of
groups
underneath our umbrella i just like to
tell people that
you know we're everything but healthcare
we're not the manchester va
you just heard from karen uh kevin
forrest and we are not the veterans home
we're everything in between so what it
did was it brought three different sort
of organizations underneath our umbrella
and they changed our name
when you look at the military affairs
aspect of our organization it's
primarily the new hampshire army and air
national guard when you look across the
number of uniformed service members
federal civilians and state employees we
number just over three thousand
now the national guard mission we call
it a mission triad it's quite simple
our federal mission is to fight and win
our nation's wars you know our state
mission is to secure the homeland
and we talk about securing the homeland
is quite simple you'll save lives
mitigate human suffering
and we also build partnerships yo if you
want to talk later on during the
question and answer period i can answer
any questions you may have about our
coveted response or anything we have
going on today
so let's now go into the military
affairs aspect of it all
um as i alluded to earlier this myself
is the adjutant general
and my deputy adjutant general um
representative baldesaro knows quite
well as a colonel retired warren perry
you're with the big two and what this um
legislation did when it made the dmavs
is it allowed commissioner and deputy
commissioner-level
advocacy for veterans across a portfolio
of different
organizations committees for us to
advocate for those veterans
um the big three that we now do we've
always had the veterans
cemetery and we're now in charge of the
division of veterans services
and the division of community-based
military programs
so those are the big three things so as
you scroll down
let's just briefly talk about the
division of veterans services
and these guys are on survivors island
uh they're a stand-alone department
with no really no overhead or
administrative support
there's ten of them we have seven
full-time veteran service officers
it's all about veteran benefits and as
you look at the slide you can see the
things that they do the services they
provide
but it's all about providing veterans
with the appropriate
benefits that they have earned through
their military service
the beauty of this reorganization is
you're the human resources the financial
the administrative support behind the
curtain
is now covered so they can spend more
time dealing and helping veterans
you can look and see what their
throughput is you know they're averaging
over 300 appointments a month
they do exceptional work and they will
rotate and travel throughout the
state you know unfortunately right now
because of covad
most appointments or all appointments
are virtual but it really hasn't stopped
then with the volume of what they're
doing per month
when you look at the what's called the
division of community-based military
programs
it's two state employees they used to be
a part of department of health and human
services
they now fall underneath us to dmavs and
they are primarily our community
outreach uh organization and i'll give
you two things and you'll see about a
little bit later on
is um but let's take this thread about
the number of veterans there's a hundred
thousand veterans in the state of new
hampshire
you just heard from the manchester va
that 25 000 veterans get care from the
manchester va
10 000 veterans get care from the white
river junction va
that leaves 65 000 veterans getting care
through their primary care provider
so one of the initiatives we have and
we've and you'll see it in a subsequent
slide is this
ask the question campaign so if you're
if you're a veteran you go to a primary
care provider you can simply ask that
what's supposed to happen is that
the primary care care provider says you
know are you a veteran
and if it's yes it then
puts you into a set of subsequent
questions to tailor the response to that
care for that veteran different
you know part of us getting after mental
health issues part of us trying to
tackle suicide
so it's really sort of a whole of
government approach
to you know trying to take care and um
advocate for our veterans
um so there's two of them the two
employees and now they report to us
and finally last but not least is the
veterans cemetery
and uh i think its mission statement is
um
is quite obvious to maintain and provide
a dignified
final resting place to honor all
veterans and their families
um again we're a rather lean state
organization
we have about 10 state employees nine
full-time one part-time at the state
veterans cemetery
and based upon the demographics and the
age of our state's veteran population
we are seeing like a large or high
number of interments
through last year and this year so i
think the month of december
we had the largest amount of internments
for casket burials
ever in the uh cemetery's history so
it's a lean organization
um you know unfortunately because of the
age of our world war ii and korea
veterans
um it's just they are very very busy at
um at that location at the cemetery you
can see from the slide that a couple of
the um
you know signature events that we host
there at memorial day the hundred nights
of remembrance
and the reach across bosca win
and finally i don't want to belabor it
is the state business administration
office
that's like i said alluded to earlier
that's the administrative or support
that helps these leaner organizations
tackle and get after the veteran aspect
of uh
advocating for our veterans
finally hopefully you're seeing slide
for this titled initiatives
i won't go through all of them i covered
one of them the ask the question ask
link collaborate 2.0 and the beauty of
that is um
like i alluded to earlier you now have
department level advocacy for veterans
so i sit on the governor's commission of
alcohol and other drugs of which i
chair the joint military task force it
allows us to advocate for
you know we have three lines of effort
it's always service members
families and the veteran community and
we advocate for you know how can we help
each one of those sort of groups of uh
constituents
and then with warren also sits as my
delegate on the council of housing
stability
so like i said like you know we are
present at a lot of places you know
we're always president
uh when representative baldesaro sits on
this uh state veterans advisory council
so we believe we're at the appropriate
level
meetings to advocate for the veterans
throughout the state for
any issue other than health care
and then we're you know we work quite
we're really in tune and um
with kevin force in the manchester va
and peggy lebreck from the veterans home
and i think we tied all together one
initiative i'd like to before i get to
the final slide is to just
you know discuss a little bit about is
um it's called the veterans friendly
business recognition program
and if you don't remember anything of
which i say today please remember this
one line
service member for life you know that's
why we are so passionate about those of
us in uniform for those
that came before us but it's all about
being a service member soldier for life
um you know the day you take off that
uniform doesn't make
make you lose those values you're still
a valuable contributing member of
communities in our society and we
advocate for that
you know one initiative we started this
past year through our division of
community-based military programs
was his veterans friendly business
recognition event
and we've got it from scratch and we had
a virtual event
about a month ago in partnership with
employment security
to acknowledge 19 businesses throughout
the state
who provide services or resources that
support veterans in our state
it was exceptional it was the first
event ever and we're we're really
excited and rolling that out and seeing
what's falling with more to come for
next year
then finally my last slide that
hopefully you can see it's called
current legislative priorities
um there's a lot of things in the
legislature right now
those are the some one some of the ones
that you know we are
you know say focused on and if i would
have to ask it would be for your support
in some of these endeavors
and the first one is it's uh you know
senator carson put an lsr
1066 for us and what we're trying to do
is
you know we have well the ultimate
challenge for us
is the biggest challenge for the
department of defense
as an all-volunteer force is to maintain
the future sessions of people joining
our force
today 71 of today's youth is ineligible
for
military service eighty percent of
our new recruits come from a military
family
we are the dire consequences from trying
to fill our formations to get that next
generation to serve
last year we changed the statute that
allowed
um soldiers and airmen when they joined
the new hampshire national guard get
free tuition at a state university it's
a tuition waiver
usually occurred after they completed
their basic and advanced military
training or their tech school
we changed that statute to now be that
the day you raise your hand and you
swear into the new hampshire national
guard
with this army or air you're now
entitled to that benefit of a tuition
waiver in state university
so that helps us with sort of the
recruiting and accessions um
it's not enough um there's no line at
our door
uh we are constantly struggling to
recruit that next generation
specifically in the army
and what this legislation does is
we would change what was a state
scholarship fund to an
enlistment incentive program that would
allow a financial incentive to a
guardsmen
of the lower ranks can get another
person to join our formation
that's why it's so important the house
bill
117 that's really it was approved last
legislative
cycle it was unfortunately vetoed in an
on the bus package
and representative graham i think is
advocating for that one on our behalf
again
lsr 353 self-explanatory
and finally the last legislative cycle
um veterans there was a veterans bill of
right that was proposed and approved and
passed
um you know it mandated certain things
for us to do
um the fiscal note that we provided said
you know we can't do without the
resources and we require
three additional staff if you want us to
do the things that are listed on the
the slide so i would just say that as
you take a look uh
and you have to make decisions this
legislative cycle
would be honored to do it uh we just
don't have the depth to do it
without the resources and subject to
your questions that's all i have
okay um brad do we have any questions
for the general
anonymous panelists but does look like
um edwards and attendees does have his
hand raised i'm not sure if you want to
recognize him
yeah i recognize the colonel lieutenant
colonel i should say in the army
he can complained to the general uh uh
thank you mr chairman
um i i am currently serving as the uh
chair of the
uh veterans affairs caucus
of the house and and in that position i
would like to ask the general
if he's uh thinks that they may support
or have a position on
a bill that would
have new hampshire law become consistent
with federal law
when it comes to having veterans
disability pay
garnished in a divorce for alimony
currently federal law says that
that disability pay is meant to go
directly to the veteran and is not to be
divided amongst family members but in
new hampshire
they are uh the courts are are
garnishing disability pay and i'm just
curious if uh
if you all will be taking a position on
that
sir i assume we will i'm just not
familiar enough with this
this uh legislation to comment on it
right now i'm gonna have to do some
research with warren
to see what its impacts are okay and
and as a follow-up will mr perry be
sticking around for the full year you
think
is he getting ready to retire from his
retiring
uh i hope he's saying i hope he's
sticking around for the full year
okay because he's been great to work
with oh yeah he's exceptional
thank you ron's not going nowhere he's
here to stay
general um i'm actually the sponsor of
that bill
uh and of course i'm sure you'll see
more about it because it's causing some
of our veterans to be homeless
and for the federal law it's not a
marital asset
but somehow uh the judges have put that
disability into the formula when it
comes to
child support in other and the federal
law states that there's an apportionment
that's a requirement
to be sent to the va the department of
veterans are fierce for approval
through the courts to the va uh and not
just automatically take the money out
but that's another day
but i uh are there any other questions
for the general
i'm not saying any hands raised okay
general i want to thank you very much
and we look forward to working with you
for the next two years
all right sir hey thanks again for your
time all right thank you
okay um we have up uh peggy lebreck uh
the countdown for the um
veterans home um i
can speak on behalf i've been fortunate
to work with her for quite a few years
i've done a great job over there taking
care of veterans and
you've got the floor
good morning sorry about that took me a
minute to uh unmute myself
um hopefully you can see um in front of
you my screen
we can thank you so for more than a
century the new hampshire veterans home
has been providing
a nursing home level of care to our
veterans
our mission is to provide the best
quality of care to our veterans with
dignity
honor and respect and we do that by
providing again nursing home level of
care
for those of you who may not know we are
a 250
bed nursing home 150 of those beds
are known as the welch or the tar units
and those are for veterans pretty much
who have capacity who most of them are
heavily medical
but they do not have um a risk of
wandering
um a hundred of those beds live on our
life enhancement dementia unit
known as ledu and those are the beds
that are for those
veterans who have dementia cognitive
impairment
or any other form of memory loss
and they are only behind those doors
if they are a danger to themselves of
wandering
and going outside at temperatures
that we wouldn't want them to we have
383 full-time equivalent staff
and again we are an intermediate
long-term care facility
offering a broad range of care to our
veterans
and again we are the only home
in the state of new hampshire that cares
for only
veterans we provide resident centered
care
that includes physical therapy
occupational therapy
speech therapy dietary services
palliative and hospice care
as well as spiritual care each one of
our residents are assigned a social
worker
so that they can have all of their needs
met just by
asking a question or being assessed by
one of our nursing professionals
we have a very robust therapeutic
recreation program
focuses on keeping our residents as
active as possible
and engaged to avoid the problems of
loneliness and depression
it treats the residents as individuals
and encourages them to explore leisure
activities
that enhance their quality of life
on a regular basis our residents are
involved in resident council meetings
and other key committees throughout the
home we have quality of life meetings
our board of managers meetings which
meets on a monthly basis
and i won't go and read the um the list
of activities as you can see there
and again we have a very robust
intergenerational program
that includes children from local
schools as you can imagine
the new hampshire veterans home has been
directly impacted by covid19
as we adhere to public health guidelines
and as of march our doors were closed
to um indoor inside visits or in in
person visits
during the summer we were able to open
up to some outside visits
for a couple of months as we held covet
19 at bay
we were able to have family members come
as long as they were gowned up
and had mass on and be able to visit
with their family members unfortunately
as of november 10th we had a
positive uh covet outbreak in the home
and so
again we were unable to provide
visitation here at the home
but please know that the recreational
staff
has done ipads skype visits
one-on-one facetime visits
with family members and our veterans as
well as those veterans who live on the
tar welch units are able to have cell
phones
so they are to able to call their loved
ones
at will
the other thing i wanted to go into is
eligibility for our veterans
each state across the nation is
different on our eligibility
we are enabled by our um are established
under chapter 119
of the rsas and so all
active duty um uh veterans who served in
the armed forces
under defined under 38 usc section 101
but what new hampshire does that's very
different than other states is we've
included our reserve units
for our army and our air national guard
as long as they
were honorably discharged they are
eligible to come and live at the new
hampshire veterans home
each one of these veterans must have
lived for one year in the state of new
hampshire
or as i would call be a son or a
daughter of new hampshire
where their dd214 states they went into
the service from new hampshire or they
returned home
from to new hampshire to be eligible
to live at the new hampshire veterans
home
and of course the final eligibility is
that the fact that the new hampshire
veterans home are actually able to care
for
that veteran and one instance that i
will um
tell you is the only time in the last
probably year
um is if we feel that that veteran is a
danger to himself or others and not able
to live in community
all of our neighborhoods are open
neighborhoods where
the smallest number is approximately 14
veterans living on a neighborhood and so
we would not want to have
someone admitted to that neighborhood
who was a danger to others
uh some of our initiatives that we have
been working on the last
year uh we are putting in a new brand
new nurse call stations throughout the
home
um that has been um
kind of delayed due to the covid
pandemic
but that it has been input into all
areas that are not residential
neighborhoods
and we are waiting until we can get the
um that wrapped up
we have a sprinkler system upgrade and
repair being done
again they're working around the areas
where the residents live in
we have a heat bump heat pump
replacement out to bid
currently with public works we've done
many security upgrades around the
home as well as cameras in common areas
and cameras in the parking lots
to maintain the safety of both our staff
and residents
one of the other initiatives that we're
working on currently is we have
a staffing issues we currently are
looking for
18 lnas
[Music]
two lpns eight rns over a variety of
shifts
so what we're doing is we've actually
are working with
the licensing bureau of licensing to
provide our own education
and training program to anybody who's
interested in becoming an lna
and so we are doing a grassroots effort
to grow our own
so if we have dietary housekeeping or
laundry staff who would like to take
that training
we are going to be providing that and we
will be a licensed facility
in order to get more lnas
into the field
one of the other of our initiatives that
i did not include
on this list was we are enhancing our
electronic medical record
which currently we are doing business
with point click
care we would like our lab that we do at
different locations able to be
downloaded directly into that electronic
medical record
currently right now our medical records
staff have to scan them in
to the records um
and that is my update um
and al our representative baldassaro sir
i'll turn it over to you if you have any
questions
yeah um i'm sure somebody's gonna have
some questions but before we go to the
the committee i remember a few years ago
there was a study that was done and when
you were speaking it popped in my brain
there
um did the nursing home the veterans
home ever get certified
certified with hoosier with the state or
like other nursing homes are required to
be certified
uh we get certified every year through
the va um
va central office we are not certified
through the central
um medicare or medicaid services is that
what you
see right now is there any benefit to
being certified to the medicare you know
to these other programs
that they have there when we looked into
it there was not
in fact we have um we are in a better
position
as we sit because as a state agency
we can get into some of their programs
through cms
but are not um have as many and actually
the va survey process mirrors the cms
process like jayco
and so all the care standards of care
are the same
um so they're really when we looked at
it monetarily
um there was not a um
not a good reason to we don't lose no
money from medicare or medicaid or
anything because you're still getting
this burdened for the va right
that is correct we have we receive per
diem from the va
for every resident that is in bed per
day and then
we get a higher per diem for any
residents that are 70 to 100 percent
it's known as the full pay so based on
their rug scores
we receive a certain dollar per resident
per bed
um so it's two different um calculations
based on the days in bed
okay thank you my last question for you
is i know
not only you but other nursing homes
having problems with hiring staff
rockingham county we just raised the um
you know the hour the wages
and for nurses lpns and everyone else in
that the category uh have you i did
did we do that recently for the for you
uh
at governor and council we went forward
approximately
i want to say five years ago
representative and got a 20
enhancement for our nursing um level
employees
so those are licensed nurses and lpns
the um people that we feel that probably
are lagging behind in that
is that um licensed nursing assistants
do not qualify
to be on the same scout salary scale
as nurses so that's where we've had
a little bit of lag on the salaries
we have worked with both the governor's
office and the union to try to see what
we can do
to look at that via an enhancement
and or a shift differential for those
staff members all right thank you
graduated are there any questions
representative uh buckowitz has their
hand up
okay representative thank you for taking
my question
i'm just wondering with the shortage in
staffing um has there been any
connection with say
for example the state nursing programs
like keene state college
as a nursing program should be ahead of
that program be
supplying students who are close to
being
rnas rns rather
um to help out we do have
a um an agreement with both unh
plymouth state and so whenever they have
nursing students that need to do their
clinicals
prior to the coven 19 we've had them
come in
and been very fortunate that many of
them will work
whether it's on you know school
vacations and weekends and nights when
they can
um and we've been very fortunate with
the social worker program as well that
we
again we did internships here so we were
able to what i would call
cherry pick um some wonderful students
from those
in the last year we've seen less of that
due to the
um i would say the covid19 scare
that many of the students um were
less less willing to come into it under
the nursing home
facility okay
any other questions thank you i'm saying
no other hands raised
all right peg peggy i want to thank you
very much and we appreciate your help
and uh
educating the committee thank you sir
all right have a good day before we
bring on
uh the chairman of state veterans
advisory committee paul lloyd
give you a little information about him
paul also sits on the board
uh at the new hampshire veterans home
but he's also the state vfw
uh adjutant okay so and even though he
served in the navy i don't hold it
against him
so uh without further delay uh let's
invite
uh the chairman of the state veterans
advisory committee
which is a statutory committee and there
are two state reps that sit on it
and two senators that sit on that
committee and he'll brief you on the
rest of it
paul flo's yours good morning everybody
thank you al i appreciate the
introduction
and the invite to come give you a brief
synopsis of what the s fact does
um under rsa 115 a
states that a veterans advisory
committee be formed
composed of two senators appointed by
the speaker
by the president of the senate and two
representatives appointed by the speaker
of the house
and members of various veteran
organizations
the members shall elect the chairman of
vice chairman and secretary from the
committee membership
since 2002 the committee has generally
met monthly
except for july and august
during the two-month summer recess
period for the legislature
the committee adopted bylaws as of june
2004 to govern management and operation
these bylaws were most recently updated
in february of 2020.
during the 2007 legislative legislative
session
the governor signed an amendment to rsa
a8 increasing the voting membership of
the sfac
from 10 to 14 veterans organizations
in the state of new hampshire in 2008
the authorized number of voting
organizations
was reached and sb-15 introduced in the
2009 session
was adopted to increase the membership
to a maximum of 20
organizations plus the two legislative
members from both the senate and the
house
the svac is currently comprised of 19
member organizations
the committee encourages any new
hampshire veterans service organization
to attend our meetings a significant
number of
of advisers guests and representatives
from our congressional delegation
participate in the meetings
in recognition of the mutual value of
shared communications
and collaboration on veterans issues
we continue to work with members of the
new hampshire house and senate to
develop our support and testimony
agenda for legislative actions on behalf
of veterans
this committee can and will help to
develop new legislation
for veterans legislators are encouraged
to review bill language with the
committee prior to or during the filing
period to ensure the svac understands
the intent of the legislation
we can help avoid unintended
consequences and clarify technical
jargon
the committee has focused on our mission
of providing a common voice for new
hampshire's
veterans and their families our meetings
provide a forum for announcing
legislative or policy changes
veterans health care updates and
scheduled events that benefit veterans
our monthly meetings which some of you
attended this month's
meeting a couple weeks ago
shows that we get briefed
from both va's manchester and white
river junction
and we get a briefing from the
governor's office
and the congressional delegation uh
both senators and um congressman custer
and
congressman pappas send a representative
as well
and uh currently we are um i think
there's five
lsrs that we're tracking um
just five of them that we're tracking so
for currently anyways and uh that's
that's
about what we have in a nutshell um
and i stand for uh to answer any
questions
okay are there any questions
representative
has his hand has his hands raised okay
go ahead represent
thank you mr chairman um uh mr lloyd i
was just wondering if you'd read the uh
five lsr numbers not you don't need to
go into them just so that i can read
them just so i know what your
legislative priorities are
well right now the lsrs that we are
tracking
are um 53 number 53 relative to the use
of force
at national guard facilities
353 relative to gold star family decals
391 relative to the treatment of
veterans i think that's a that's a house
bill now right
that
559 relative to an extended term of
imprisonment for assaulting military
personnel
and 696 requiring the governor's
permission before the new hampshire
national guard can be deployed overseas
thank you appreciate that yes sir you're
welcome
are there any other questions now i
i am a voting member on the state
veterans advising committee i've been on
there for many many years
and have worked on legislation with uh
with them
to move forward with more seats and
other stuff there they do a great job i
would recommend
that every representative on there at
least guilt at one meeting and get on
their mailing list
or send paul uh your email to be added
to the list so
you can be informed of what goes on
because there
these groups uh veterans organizations
throughout the whole state
that speak out on legislation that helps
you know that goes against veterans i'll
give you an idea
i sponsored legislation on the veterans
plate i
met actually sponsored a lot of
legislation on veterans stuff
throughout the years but they come
together
veterans organizations and have their
input in there
now we legislators reserve the right to
say thank you
or say no thank you on their on their uh
recommendations and paul knows it once
or twice
said no thank you but but 99 percent of
the time we've
been on the same sheet of music with the
state veterans
advisory committee so we do work hand in
hand with them
and it's a great uh statutory committee
that we're probably one of the very few
states in the country
that do this and i want to thank paul
are there any other questions out there
that's any hands raised okay uh paul
thank you very much we appreciate you
coming on thank you
for the invite y'all have a good day
okay give me a second here and i'm going
to put back up my um
thing here we're actually doing pretty
good we're ahead
uh schedule here um not bad for a zoo
meeting huh
okay um if you take a look at uh the
agenda here i
i try to make life easy for you all to
understand
what the function of the committee is
and if you take a look at what i put up
in front of you you know and you can
read that
it gives you an idea what our committee
is involved in
you know and it should be the duty of
the committee on state federal asian
veterans of fears
to consider all matters pertaining to
the national guard
and other military or veterans
organizations within the state
potential actions by the u.s congress
which will have a major impact on the
state in the new
new england region and all proposed
resolutions petitioning
the congress are any matter to maintain
communications
with the congressional delegation to
serve as a liaison between
new hampshire house and the united
states congress emergency management and
such other matters as may be referred to
it
okay and that isn't within our rules of
the house
and every year that when we vote on our
rules
that is what goes on now
if you go down to the bottom real quick
and you'll see
uh where i get up here on the different
types of
resolutions that come forward let me see
if i can get them all
in here okay
uh that we deal with on the four types
of uh resolutions
um this we're gonna have a problem with
resolutions and the reason why
is when years ago the house and senate
boat heard resolutions
over the last five years four or five
years or so the senate
refused to hear resolutions from the
house and they have a policy there
where it will take only a certain
percentage of the senators
agree and then they will take on a
resolution
so even though we pass a resolution in
committee
that does not mean that um it's going to
happen it's going to go forward
okay um now you all you should have got
that that i sent you on the rules of the
committee
okay um so you have an idea
on what goes on in the committee or
what's required by
the house we work off rules
okay and i'm a i'm a process guy i'm a
stickler on the roof as linda
mastermiller will tell you
and uh you know and make sure that the
committee is in compliance with the
rules
very focused on mason rules also for our
committee
so if you see something that's going not
being done
properly bring it up
you know bring it up uh do not be as you
know uh set back
and you know let it go if you know
something's being done
wrong because even though i've been on
that committee for years been the
chairman before vice chair
i'm not perfect and i'm far from perfect
so i'll be the first one to tell you
okay but we're a team and we'll work
together we'll make sure we're in the
requirement
you know in accordance with the rules
now let me see what my agenda here
one thing i want to add in there um if
you notice here i have a cup of coffee
at my desk here past chairmans have
uh made rules and say oh no coffee know
this no that
you know some you you're taking the time
out you're making a hundred dollars a
year
coming up to the state house to do the
people's business i have no issues with
you having a cup of coffee at your desk
where we're having hearings i have no
issues
with you having a pad at the desk
but i don't what we don't want to see is
the big la lap sitting behind laptops
okay and being on a laptop the whole
time or somebody's speaking
so if you have a pad that lays down or i
got no problem on you
because as some will tell you there i
have a reputation
of uh when somebody says something and i
believe it's true or being able to be
brought out the wrong way i always look
up
trust i believe in trust by verify see
linda laffin over there
okay so uh you know that's me and to
make sure that you get the right
information because there's certain
times i will ask questions
that i i already know the answers but i
only ask those questions so the freshmen
on up will understand and know what's
going on
or what the correct answer is so
if you see me asking questions at times
it's only for the benefit of the
committee basically
and to see you know what the answer is
of the person testifying
okay because it's only fear
that you know what i know and you know
since i've been on there for 14 years
and you know
what representative master miller knows
because she's been on there for years
okay so we don't mind sharing the
knowledge there and
making it uh important what i just
noticed you're not seeing my screen
remember one sec here i just noticed
that
it again how come nobody corrected me
all right let me see is this it
yeah here we go are you seeing my screen
now
all right see now there's a temporary
setback right there because somebody
should have said they represented where
the hell is your screen
it's not up there can you all hear me
yes sir i got we can hear you okay good
i
i thought i screwed up for a second
there all right i
i thought it might have been just my
screen but now uh
i see it was everybody so we're good
we're good now i did tell you i'm not
perfect right
okay so i'm not scared to say that but
anyways um
those are the rules and the um per the
rules on the resolutions and other stuff
study those and learn them so that way
you know what goes on in committee
it is very important on the one rule
they're under 105
that are require a quorum is required to
transact business now what does that
mean
it does not mean that you need a quorum
for a um
hearing although it should it's
disrespectful if we don't have
representatives
um a majority in the committee room uh
for these people that are taking the
time out to come and speak
we owe that to the public to make sure
that we're there to listen
if for some reason you're going to be
late okay very quietly
if we're in the uh committee room walk
in and just go take a seat
some chairman rather where you wait and
stand and wait until the speaker who's
sitting there
gets done speaking i have no issue with
you
walking in quietly and go sit down if
you have to make a
uh a head call if you've got a bathroom
call or you gotta
you know for some reason you don't feel
too good or whatever just get up and
walk you walk out
of the committee room okay uh you will
notice at times i will stand
okay uh and stand behind my chair and
and
the reason for that because i have
arthritis in my pelvis people think i'm
an active guy but i have no
choice because i don't take medication
while i'm up at the state house there so
i do stand a lot so you will see me
get up out of my chair but that don't
mean i'm leaving the room i'm just
standing because i have little issues
with my spine
uh and that's the same thing with others
if you you know because some
some committee hearings are going to get
repetitious some are going to get boring
or some are going to be you know that
you're in go for an hour or two
depending on how many people show up to
testify
so if you need to get up like uh to go
take a break whatever you do that and
you come back in
but now the executive sessions are the
key
when we call for a vote in the executive
session on a bill
you have to be present if you walk
in after we call for a vote then you
will not be able to vote on that bill
so keep that in mind there when you're
getting up to walk out or where we're in
executive session
or when we're debating a bill if you had
a run to the head
if you let me know ahead of time and i
know that's where you're going and
you'll be back in a minute
then i will out of respect for democrats
and republicans i will hold up the vote
okay until you get back into the room
okay as i don't have to but i will do
that because i believe it's a team
effort that we're doing
and i at one time because a couple of
democrats have made a mistake on their
vote
and i didn't want to see him get picked
on with their other democrats
i re considered a bill for them even
because they were supporting the
republican position
but i think i don't know if
representative massa miller was with us
at the time but i reconsidered the bill
so they can vote the right way and would
not
catch hell from others because they
didn't they thought they should have
voted a certain way
so that's the type of guy i am just so
you know that yeah now
i'm trying to see now i'm going to go
around uh one at a time here and we'll
if somebody introduce yourself and
you know we can get ready to close us
out if and tell us a little bit about
yourself if you're a veteran
let us know that you're a veteran and um
that you you've been with the committee
um
okay so give everyone a chance here uh
dave lundgren you there
dave i know i've seen him on earlier
dave is a doctor
uh chiropractor so he told me he was
going to have his computer on in his
office while he was working on patients
so
let's see i don't know if he's still
there all right how about
um lawrence walks
you there i am here yeah hi
um i'm uh from keene i
teach at king state college i'm a
psychologist
and i have worked in va hospitals across
the country from
honolulu to manhattan
so i'm really interested in this area
and i'm i'm
grateful to be here thanks thank you
lawrence
okay how about phyllis catcher chorus i
didn't see her around here
phyllis is a long time member of the
committee
uh stacy uh marie laflin you're there
yes i'm here
we'll get him um well i'm uh
new to the i'll just put my camera on
i'm new to the committee
i'm stacey law and i'm from nashua and
um
been very actively involved in politics
for years
i'm not a veteran but i am a proud uh
um descendant of a veteran my father
was a part of the u.s army and um
he's quite proud that i'm on this
committee um
because i highly support our veterans
and
was a surprise to be on this committee
and i'm
really thankful to be here to be
involved in some of our
uh decisions we make for our veterans uh
thank you uh replacement do you go by
or just stacy uh you can either usually
just stacy but uh leave
it fully it's stacy marie but you can
refer just to stacy
okay the reason i'm asking that out of a
fellow i'm a personal guy my name is al
where are we we're chairman yeah you
know what i'm saying even though this is
orientation stuff there just
uh i'm not in anyone else because i'm
the chairman
yes sir okay is uh skip rollins here
i didn't see him on earlier he works
during the day okay
how about um tony labranche
hello uh i'm tony branch
uh not a veteran i'm only 19 years old
and i don't think i would be
qualifying to join any of the services
with my medical history but
i joined this committee out of the
interest
of the federal relations part and
dealing with the federal government
and i never really knew much about
veterans issues and it's always been
something i want to learn more about so
what better than to join this committee
so i'm
looking forward to working with everyone
on this committee uh
and that's all i had to say awesome
welcome
okay susan i didn't see susan on uh
dolomis
susan's the clerk
okay let me make a note there
is um amanda told me
hi how how thank you so much um my
name is um amanda elizabethtol and i'm
serving from
keene new hampshire i'm a freshman rep
and
i'm really grateful to be on this
committee um
my stepfather who's been in my life for
20 years was
career military and my sister-in-law is
currently in the reserves
and i am a small business owner and i
live with my kindergartner isaac so
um that's a little bit about me and i'm
looking forward to working with
everybody
thank you so much oh that's awesome i
mean i
i have a son who's in the marine corps
retro he's over in kuwait right now
so i know what it is to go to war and
send the sun to war
uh but do you know i'm sorry you i think
you misheard me my
my son's in kindergarten it's my it's my
stepfather
no i heard you would you step out
do you know chris roberts i do not know
chris roberts tell me about chris
roberts
chris roberts is a democrat from keene
he when i first served uh came up 14
years ago chris was the chairman
of my committee state and federal
relations when i walked into
him uh him and i served in the marines
together in the same unit we went to
desert shield together he went to one
airfield to rebuild
i went to another one so we've been
friends for years and he's
he i think he's still on your council
there in keene that's awesome i will um
try to make a connection with chris
thank you for that
all right you tell chris i said my love
yes
thank you representative david binford
[Applause]
yes i'm representing david benford i
live in bath new hampshire
um i am a united states air force
veteran
served during desert storm i am also a
united states
army veteran served in afghanistan
i am the vice chairman of asthma check
foundation which is a
veteran and first responder organization
we work to get veterans and first
responders outdoors and out of their
heads
this is my second term as a state
representative non-consecutive i served
in 2017-2018
um i guess that's pretty much about me
all right thank you david um willis
griffin
is he on okay he's not
uh william foster
thank you mr chairman well i should say
hell i'm not sure
um
we're not in uh committee uh this is
just an orientation
right okay um yeah i'm an air force
veteran
um disabled
i'm currently going through vocational
rehab and
finishing off my degree um
i'm really glad to be on this committee
and
i'm from new boston and
uh i look forward to uh serving
outstanding okay matthew wilhelm
wilhelm thank you mr chairman uh my name
is matt wilhelm
my second term representing manchester
words one two and three
uh which is where the the manchester va
is located so really uh honored
to be serving on this committee i uh
come from
a a military family my my grandfather
stormed the beaches in normandy
member of the us army and uh
really uh proud to proud to to
carry on his legacy as uh someone
involved in public service so
thanks for having me outstanding thank
you uh brody
yeshua's the shades
thank you uh yeah the chaise and thank
you mr chairman and
hello everyone i'm uh representative
brody de chase i'm a first term rep
from wolfer new hampshire and i also
want to thank everyone who came and
joined to
participate in the meeting today and
give us all that great information and
thank the
vice chairman and the chairman for
providing that so we can better
serve our constituents thank you oh
thank you uh
janet wall um her and i go back many
years there great state representative
for manchester where is she on
can you hear me we sure can i'm sorry
can you hear me
chairman we sure can welcome back
jennifer
hi i'm i'm state rep janet wall i
represent durham and madbury
i had the privilege of serving as a
substitute on your committee several
times last year and really enjoyed the
work and the people i was with
i'm in my 18th term i've served on
several committees
my mom and dad were both in world war ii
and served with distinction of course i
have done
some work for veterans over the years
and for five years
worked part-time in washington d.c
for women veterans and i live in an area
where there are lots of veterans here
in the durham area and many many
of my dear friends have served i this is
an honor
i really respect the committee and all
the people who are serving on it thank
you
thank you i made a mistake i said
manchester united
you weren't manchester um but anyway uh
representative tina holly
i didn't see her on is she on
tina okay nope
uh representative f let me get this
right f stacia
bulls russ yes did i say all right i'm
gonna what you did
good morning my name is representative
of staffia boris
also known as esther i represent
ward 6 nashua i've this is my third term
non-consecutive as well i'm also
a business owner in nashua new hampshire
i own a mortgage company which i do work
with veterans
i assist them with home ownership and
refinancing with the benefits that they
have for serving our country
i have been on this committee the last
term that i served
and i'm honored um to work with
everybody to assist our veterans
thank you very much thank you you are
representative john levette
representative bald disarro how are you
i'm doing great brother welcome back
well thank you hey if i tell you you're
my hero
can um can you get me a uh
uh parking spot in the garage well yeah
i think we might have one down there on
store street there right now
you are anyways i'm uh representing john
levitt this is my second term
uh i am a six-year us army veteran i did
serve
during peace time so all you uh combat
vets don't
uh uh hold me uh
too uh too bad i did serve honorably but
i enjoy
um i know well for a while he's he's a
great guy he supported me
um when i did serve um
in 2016 218 and i'm looking
forward to um helping out this committee
any way i can
awesome well welcome back okay
representative
uh israel pedro
is he on okay i don't see it
i say let me see did i save the last the
best for last
he was on but i don't see him now okay
uh representative linda massimo did you
like how i switched it back and forth
and just didn't go how we normally take
the votes
i was very impressed dale yes you're
doing a great job
um i just have a couple of questions
just to clarify
um as far as hearings and executive
sessions
they are going to be hybrid both
or now no the um
the regular hearings with the public
first of all right now the way it's
designed is the public
will not be coming into the state house
they'll be um
[Music]
a hybrid as far as the state reps right
now
if they cannot come in or they're scared
of the covet they're
going to give them a break on the um the
regular committee hearings then
we will do hybrid with them but
the executive sessions if you're scared
and can't come in then i want you there
to do your job
as you're elected to do then you'll have
to get a replacement
because my executive sessions will be a
face to face
okay okay and then the other question
that um
some of the members had um asked me
about
was um if you come in for in-person
session will you have to wear masks um
yes uh right now my understanding is yes
uh i'll be straightforward with you now
i have
just had an operation two months ago on
my vocal voice box
um i have sinus issues from the military
uh
my drainage it's tough for me to wear a
mask all the time
okay so uh but there's supposed to be
shields
that they're gonna put you know like
plexiglas in between and everything else
and then with the air duct system um
it's probably going to be pretty safe
uh you know in social distancing but
like i said
you're not going to see me with a mask
all the time because i just can't do it
okay but in general they will be
required but in general yes
that's been a medical reason but yes
okay
thank you very much some of us veterans
here but have spent a lot of time out in
the desert
and it really screwed us up by our eyes
and
no no tears and sinuses
and everything else okay thank you very
much
all right you're not gonna elbow me this
time are you
well i can't promise okay just checking
all right well i i tell you i i'm very
impressed with the crew that we have and
i think we're going to work great
together
i for the democrats you have an awesome
uh
ranking member and i promise to
louisiana
uh not pick on it never never and for my
fellow veterans if you're not a marine
i'll go easy on you too there
okay uh but are there any any other last
minute questions for me
seeing that there's none i will do my
damnedest to keep you informed
on what's going on once i start
scheduling and once i
once i find out the dates that we're
going to have the hearings of when
that we're going to be scheduled in
certain room with a room number
then i will put that out and let you
know what's going on i will try to keep
you informed
as what i know i want you to know okay
so
um as i get the information i will put
it out to you all
and then hopefully uh we can get this
done but i can guarantee you now one of
the benefits of being on state and
federal asian veterans affairs
is like normally we get 15 to 20 bills
the most i have esteem was 30. uh with
only nine bills right now
that gives each and every one of you an
opportunity to help out on other
committees
you know which makes a difference like
me i'm involved in a lot of bills not
just veterans
okay uh so you know this makes life a
lot easier there
i wish we had more lead pieces of
legislation
i wish we had more veterans bills than
resolutions because then we can all
hang out and be nice to each other you
know it's just when the resolutions come
forward
you know some of them they like to come
forward politics stuff and i'm not one
who likes politics stuff
okay on the resolution so you know but
we have to do what we got to do but i
want to thank each and every one of you
we've done great there i was thinking
we'd be done by 12 31
it's almost 12 o'clock you all have a
great day
and let me give you my cell number okay
um
you're all ready to copy it's
603-858-3535
and i answer every phone call and i help
every veteran in the state and around
the country
uh so if you come up across a veteran's
issue you're not really sure of
call me okay and uh we'll do everything
we can to get you in the right direction
and who to talk to
mr chair yes uh i think representative
toll has a question
i you thank you matt um
mr chairman um dude i was just wondering
if you had a sense of
when the next time we're gonna meet is
going to be
um yes um after the 18th
okay um we should know before the 18th
but after the 18th is when they're going
to start scheduling hearings
now like i said if i i don't know what
day yet i've already told the um
the uh chief of staff that i leave
thursday night sometimes for florida and
come back
sunday or monday okay so uh
in other words i trying to keep us away
from doing it on a friday and a monday
so we don't screw up your weekends all
the time
okay that's what i'm pushing for tuesday
wednesday or thursday
thank you so much okay so
time will tell brad are there any other
questions because i can't see hands up
i just haven't seen any of their hands
raised okay well you all have my phone
number
and if there's anything i can uh answer
call me i want to thank each and every
one of you once again welcome to the
committee
god bless you all and we'll see you on
the next uh
soon as i get more info information on
what we can put together
right now thank you so much bye everyone